the um
natural history museum in bozeman uh
montana has
a raptor that on one side of it they had
feathers on it to try to give you like
an alternate perspective of what it
might have looked like
they know now that the idea that all
dinosaurs were these
reptile looking things is incorrect some
of them literally were birds
so the birds that you see today whether
it's a peacock or a chicken or something
like that
they're [ __ ] dinosaurs yeah that's
what that is it's a dinosaur that
survived
the ones that are bigger than a chicken
didn't really make it why did the small
ones make it
that when the impact uh hit the world
that it was so devastating that it
killed almost everything yeah kill
and whatever was left whatever
scrounging scavenging little creature
that was left
evolved and became us we used to be a
mole we used to be like a shrew
65 million years ago that's what these
people these these non-believers
this is what they think you you think
it's ridiculous that you think you
you came from a monkey i know you know
jesus this is how crazy these liberals
are you know they
it's crazy to think you came from monkey
well these [ __ ] take it to
another level
they they're so crazy they think you
came from a shrew you were like a little
mole
character yep yup yup yup and then that
became a monkey and then adam the monkey
becomes you all that [ __ ] inside of 65
million years
get the [ __ ] out of the [ __ ]
meanwhile crocodiles are 100 million
years old so crocodiles are the same
but somehow or another we went from
being a [ __ ] shrew to being a person
who knows and loves jesus
[ __ ] that's it right there that's right
thing
so if you see like rats like there was a
i don't buy it